from Warner Brothers Studios in
Hollywood it's the Conan audience II
Awards celebrating excellence in the
sitting and looking arts here now is
your host Conan O'Brien this is he what
an honor that I would get to host this
this is amazing you know to host an
award show this big though I need to
dress the part Bruce do you mind we go
and we're done Bruce prominent everybody
no one puts on a tux
that guy shows no joy in his work he
just puts it on and then I'm out of here
and he's gone
look at this baby look at this right
here this is the audience the award
these are this may look cheap and shitty
but when you get up close when you get
up really close you can see how cheap
and shitty it really is that's the
important thing
let's get this show started our first
audience the award is for the best
impression of a celebrity and the
audience egos to the person in seat 5d
for their impression of Manny from
Modern Family
[Music]
I like the part where he's looking
around who looks like Manny from Modern
Family I wonder where he is the next
audience II award is also for best
impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seats
7j for their impression of David Spade
let's give it up David's bad
thank God
I know David Spade he looks more like
David Spade than David Spade
the next audience award is also for best
impression and the audience he goes to
the person in seat 16e for their
impression of a crowned crane
[Music]
don't smile sir you're in danger the
next audience II award is also for best
impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
14d for their impression of the dancing
lady emoji
the next audience egos the person's seat
12l it's the word for the audience
member most likely to have a clogged
shower drain
[Music]
just to guess next audience he goes the
person is seat 4b it's the award for the
audience member most likely to be Tony
Hawk's accountant
[Music]
this next award goes to person and seat
6f it's the word for the audience
remember most likely to of a mustache
that's been impacted by the California
drought
[Music]
the next audience egos the person in
seat 19 C&C word for the audience member
most likely to definitely be a narc
[Music]
[Applause]
I think I think he is a narc he's so
unhappy about being on camera mustache
looks pretty face
it sure does you can see the tape
holding it on hey let's keep going our
next audience the award goes to the
audience member who obviously is waiting
for the camera to stop on him so he can
propose to his girlfriend let's see if
we can find him wait no no you missed
him go back go back you missed him okay
there okay okay well no forget it
screw it better luck next time of course
I'm sure they'll both meet other people
of course like every award show our
music is provided by an orchestra down
in the orchestra pit they are right
behind me Jim Aveeno in the basic cable
band guys amazing job really incredible
and finally people often ask me Conan
how is this beautiful official audience
he statuette really made well it's an
interesting process and I thought I'd
share it with you sometimes when a
mommy's at the end of a long and
especially hard day and she's in the
middle of a difficult second divorce and
wondering if she can really do this all
again or she even deserves love
she needs a daddy made entirely of gold
and sure this daddy's not exactly her
type but he does have one undeniable
quality he's available things get weird
pretty fast and what this mommy and
daddy shared that night is not exactly
what you or I would call love but who
are we to judge
maybe this clumsy fumbling is the
closest thing they have in this anyway
nine months later that Mommy and Daddy
make a little gold statue and that's how
the audience
you
you